Hi everyone, my name is Sean Spitzer, Senior Instructor for Epic Games.
Today we're going to be talking about Optimization for Linear Content, Diagram and Foliage.
Some of the topics we're going to be talking about in this series is Foliage Optimization
overall when it comes to analyzing your scenes and priority areas, Optimization based on
shots, Lumen updates with Foliage and we're going to look at a little bit of how that
relates to the world partition.
Later on we'll look at Niagara Optimization, some checklists and debugging, additional
steps, FX and baking effects overall and some of the options you have there.
So let's go ahead and get started.
In the next video we'll talk about the outline and we'll start looking at analyzing your
scenes when it comes to Foliage.
Thanks again.